My husband walked out on me for one simple reason,...
...I was too honest with him.
I refused to allow him to delude himself.
Since his divorce, Alfie had his teeth whitened and his skin darkened.
You are entering a period of great fulfillment.
There's no such thing as predicting the future.
Will it be cash or check, darling?
Sally who married Roy, a washed-up writer at 38.
That's it. I quit.
He tried to earn money. He just wasn't much of a chauffeur.
All that cheered him up was the beautiful creature in red across the way.
Sorry, am I disturbing you?
No, not at all.
You inspire me.
I've always wanted to be someone's muse.
I can't be in this marriage.
That man you work for, you know, the one who you are so high on.
Wow! Wow!
Don't rule him out.
Roy and I are getting a divorce.
Do you see how ironic and beautiful life is?
And just when you think things can't possibly get any worse,...
I see a handsome stranger coming in to your life.
His wife died and he's been trying so desperately to contact her.
I love you.
...fate lets you know there's bigger trouble out there.
He left me for another woman.
No!
A deceased one.
Shakespeare said, "Life was full of sound and fury"...
..."and in the end, signified nothing".
You will meet a tall dark stranger.
Wow! That's exciting news!